We have been given five digits one, two, three, four, and five.
And along with that we have this question.
Using these five digits,
how many three-digit odd numbers can be formed?
First case when repetition is not allowed.
And second when repetition is allowed.
By repetition not being allowed,
they mean we cannot consider numbers like,
131 or 224 which have repeated digits.
Let's understand the first part.
Read the question well.
How many three-digit odd numbers? Odd is the key word here.
As we have been asked for three-digit numbers,
let's make three slots.
What do we mean by odd?
A number is odd, if it is not divisible by 2.
Is 342 odd? No, it's not odd as it is divisible by 2.
What about 531?
Is this odd? Yes it is. Because it is not divisible by 2.
Similarly, 325 and 243 are odd.
In simple words this three-digit number will be odd,
if it's unit digit is odd.
So based on the condition we have,
the three-digit number can end with a '1' or end with a '3' or end with a '5'.
Correct!
These are the only three possibilities here.
Now focus on the first possibility.
The number ends with a '1'.
In how many ways can we fill the first slot or the hundredth slot?
What do you think?
The digit 1 is gone.
So the hundredths place can be filled with any one
of the remaining four digits 2, 3, 4 or 5.
4 ways in which it can be filled.
What about the second slot? The digit 1 is gone.
And another digit out of these 4 is gone into the hundredths place.
Only three digits remain.
So the second slot can be filled in three ways.
With 1 in the unit's place,
and as we are filling the first and the second slot we multiply this.
'And' is always multiplication.
Four times three is twelve.
Given these five digits,
there are twelve ways in which we can form a three-digit number
with one as its units digit.
Are we done?
No! We still have to look at these two cases.
In the second case, the digit 3 is gone.
The first slot can be filled with one or a two or a four or a five.
Four ways.
As two digits are gone the tenth place can be filled in three ways.
Again, as we are filling the first and the second slot,
we have a multiplication sign here.
Given these five digits, there are 12 ways in which we can form
a three-digit number with 3 as its units digit.
And similarly we get a 12 here as well.
Let's zoom out slightly!
What do we do with these three numbers?
Do we add them or multiply them?
To know the answer just use plain English.
The unit's digit is 1 & 3 & 5?
Or should we say that the unit's digit can be
1 or 3 or a 5?
Of course, it's an 'or'.
Based on the condition given, the unit's digit can be 1 or 3 or 5.
An 'or' implies plus .
Adding these three we get the answer as 36 ways.
36 ways in which we can form three-digit odd numbers,
using these five digits.
Now this was slightly long and a more logical way of solving this.
Now that we know the concept.
Let's look at a quicker way to solve it.
We know it is a three-digit number.
What is the condition given to us?
The condition is that the number should be odd.
Remember a Golden rule.
Whenever we are given a condition, start with it.
As the condition is about the numbers being odd,
we can be sure that it depends on the unit's digit.
So we start off with the unit's digit slot.
In how many ways can we fill this slot ?
It can be filled with a one or a three or a five.
Three ways.
Now we can move on to the other two slots.
One digit is gone. It doesn't matter what digit it is.
If one digit is gone then four remain.
The hundredth place can be filled in four ways.
If the unit's digit is filled with one,
any digit from two, three, four or five can be in the hundredth place.
If the unit's digit is filled with three
any digit from one to four or five
can be in the hundredth place.
And when two digits are used for the
hundredth and the unit's place, just three remain.
The second slot can be filled in three ways.
And we multiply these to get the answer thirty-six ways.
We got the same answer, but a lot quicker.
Some of you would be thinking,
why start with the condition? What if we don't?
Let's say we decide to start with the hundredth place.
In how many ways can we fill the hundredth place digit?
We can fill it with any of the five digits.
Five ways.
Having used one digit here,
the tenth place can be filled in four ways.
And now we come to the unit's place.
In how many ways can we fill the unit's place?
Can we say three ways as three digits are left?
Maybe not.
Let's say we used a one here.
We have two, three, four, and five left.
Say I pick a three here.
Now in how many ways can the unit's digit be filled?
It has to be odd.
The only odd digit that remains is five.
It can be filled in just one way and that's five.
Let's take another scenario,
Say we fill the hundredth place with two and we picked a four in the tens place.
Now tell me in how many ways can we fill the unit's digit?
One, three, or five. All will keep the number odd.
In this case there are three ways in which the unit's digit can be filled.
So we end up with conflicting answers if we don't start with the condition.
When forming numbers, remember to start with the condition.
There are 36 ways in which we can form three-digit odd numbers
using these five digits
if repetition is not allowed.
And what if repetition is allowed?
Remember,
life becomes really easy if repetition is allowed.
Let's solve it on a new page.
Using these five digits,
how many three-digit odd numbers can be formed if repetition is allowed?
Okay, let's solve the second part.
We are talking about three-digit numbers here, and they have to be odd.
Let's start with the condition.
In how many ways can we fill the unit's digit?
As the number has to be odd,
we can fill the unit's digit with either a '1' or a ''3 or a '5'.
3 ways in which the unit's digit can be filled.
We are done with the condition.
In how many ways can we fill the hundredth place now?
What do you think?
As one digit is used here,
the hundredth place can be filled in four ways. Correct?
No, it's not.
Don't forget,
repetition is allowed!
We can use the same digit here as well.
Five ways in which the hundredth place can be filled.
Any one of the five digits,
and what about the tenth place?
Again it can be filled with any one of the five digits, five ways.
As we are filling the first and the second and the third slot,
we multiply these numbers.
We get the answer as 75 ways.
There are 75 three-digit odd numbers,
we can form using these five digits if repetition is allowed.
Here's my last question in this session.
If repetition is allowed, do we have to start with the condition?
Let's say we start with the hundredth place.
It can be filled with any of the five digits.
It will be the same with the tenth digit as repetition is allowed.
And the unit's digit again ,can be filled in three ways.
The answer does not change even if we start with the hundredth place.
If repetition is allowed, we don't really have to start with the condition.
Don't stress yourself out by having to remember this.
As a general rule just start with the condition.
That's how we deal with numbers with a condition.
We will cover a few more interesting examples
in the coming sessions.